[Music]
what happens when kids get together with
their parents to throw epic birthday
parties mind-blowing unforgettable fun
wait until you see the party that will
turn everyone into a rockstar if you're
new to the things make sure to subscribe
to our channel do you want to be a DIY
expert check out our friends at crafty
hackers they have the best hacks crafts
and everything DIY watch their videos
for the best household tricks DIY decor
and fun recipes if you love making
crafts with your friends or just trying
new things they have everything you're
looking for be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any awesome hacks and
crafts
now here are 10 epic kids birthday party
ideas party at Hogwarts this crafty mom
transformed her home into a Harry Potter
wonderland for her lucky kid she
transformed her front door into platform
9 and 3/4 by making a brick wall out of
a sheet and it wouldn't sign near the
door she made a couple of slits in the
sheet so the kids could run through just
like in the movie this super mom made a
Hogwarts flag to hang outside too then
she sewed robes for all the kids to wear
so they could pretend to be in the
School of wizardry and witchcraft just
like their favorite characters after
they put on their robes the children
were escorted to the Ollivanders 1 shop
where they could choose a handcrafted
wooden wand
they were then invited to decorate their
wines with markers and stuff Phoenix
feathers
jewels and dragon scales into the hollow
of the wands this party is so cool the
mom made a talking sorting hat out of
crumbled paper bags and a baby monitor
which the dad spoken to and assigned
each child a house the kids then went to
potions class and made their own potions
in small cauldrons after potions they
went outdoors to play Quidditch what an
awesome party under the stars this 11
year olds mother wanted to create a
party that matched her sparkly
personality so she created a star themed
party called under the stars a glitzy
dinner table was set under the patio
overhang which was decorated with
twinkling string lights
they really glowed as the Sun sat in the
backyard the table was set with glittery
paper and utensils with pink star place
whole
the dessert table was full of yummy
treats such as Milky Way candy bars milk
bottles decorated with stars and star
shaped cookies they played games like
shoot for the stars where they shoot
marshmallows out of marshmallow guns
they decorated their own telescopes for
stargazing and they had a nail painting
section for the star treatment there was
also a dress-up area and a photo booth
to give the kids a chance to be movie
stars there was even a dream station
that served star berry soda and
sparkling soda and lemonade the girls
all waved sparklers in the night air as
they sang happy birthday then they
watched a movie under the stars while
snacking on some yummy pink starburst
SIM popcorn for party favors the mom all
made the partygoers t-shirts that said
shine on the front what a lovely way to
turn 11 the amazing race party this
family of amazing race fans were
ecstatic about throwing this amazing
race themed party first they sent out
invitations with a copy to show logo
when the day came it was race time the
kids were given instructions at the end
of the street then they were off to find
their first clue on the front porch
their first quest was to put a golf ball
in a spoon and walk the length of the
driveway without dropping it after that
they had to rush to the neighbor's house
to memorize a poem that was posted on
the front door after they memorized the
poem they had to come back to the party
house to recite the poem for a judge
once they got the poem right they ran
for the next task they were given the
choice to either eat something spicy or
make butter then there was a goodies
eating challenge followed by
instructions to write nice things on
posters about each party goer their last
challenge was to put together a puzzle
and run out to a spot in the backyard
the winning team got a goodie bag full
of treats the neon glow-in-the-dark
party 11 year old amber got this idea
from an issue of the American Girl doll
magazine she was so excited about a
colorful neon glow-in-the-dark dance
party she was easily able to convince
her mom to make it happen before the
party started they decked out the room
with black lights a disco ball and loud
dance music the party guests were
encouraged to wear white or neon when
they arrived they were greeted with a
selection of jnana
accessories to put on they could choose
from colorful neon socks head bands
glowing bracelets flashing rings and
disco ball necklaces there were also
extra white and neon clothes to choose
from for anyone who wanted them then
each kid had their picture taken the
pictures were printed out for a color
pop art activity the kids a trained
vogue Itza and Cheetos for dinner for
dessert they eight color blast cupcakes
and glowing cotton candy and drinks that
had neon food coloring in them there was
also multicolored brownies right colored
push pops and of course a neon birthday
cake after eating the guests had their
faces painted with a neon paint and
danced the night away a Nancy Drew
mystery party this party is a bit
old-school the whole party centers
around solving a mystery the decorations
were made from vintage clocks book pages
and book covers and an old typewriter
guys they even had keys made out of
chocolate then the guests arrived they
found a ransom note which said they're
party favors had been stolen and they
must leave a ransom in a red wagon if
they ever want to see them again
each guest was outfitted with a
detective cape and given a detective kit
to help them find clues to solve the
case the kids had flashlights magnifying
glasses and fingerprinting kits inside
the kids looked through the house for
clues as newly appointed mystery solvers
when they guessed solve the crime they
called the authorities and had the
perpetrator played by a willing cousin
put in a makeshift gel there was even a
spot for the adults to sit and sip
coffee as the little detectives
interviewed them about the mystery the
party was a big hit The Incredibles the
incredible sequel is right around the
corner so it's only natural that young
fans would want to have their own
superhero party this one is pretty cute
first they made invitations for the
party that looked like newspapers it had
a picture of the birthday boy dressed as
mr. incredible with a headline that read
calling off superheroes mr. incredible
needs you the invitation promised to get
the superheroes into shape and with
superhero training and superhero
nutrition when they guests arrived they
were able to watch a bit of the movie to
get inspired then it was time for their
super healthy super snacks this mom
opted for healthier options like fruits
and vegetables once they were all fueled
up with muscle boosting
they went to superhero training the
youngsters lifted weights to build
muscle and ran around a track like -
there was a superhero obstacle course
planned - and then the pinata the goody
bags were decorated with the Incredibles
logo then syndrom came out to have a
final battle he was ultimately defeated
and the little superheroes saved the day
a backyard camping party this kid
celebrated his ninth birthday by
inviting his friends to come to camp
Tyler this family transformed their
backyard into a campground for Tyler and
his friends they set up a bonfire
pitched a tent and roasted hot dogs and
marshmallows under the stars the party
had a table full of yummy camping
favorites
it had hotdogs chocolate graham crackers
and marshmallows for making s'mores
chili and chips and cake pops for
dessert
there was trail mix and root beer - the
invitation looks like a camping pass
inviting guests to reserve their spots
before the Sun went down and the
partygoers went on a nature hunt they
had a checklist of things to find
including a pinecone a green leaf a flat
rock and a woodchip after the Sun went
down and they finished roasting
marshmallows and eating birthday cake
the kids played a game of flashlight tag
under the night sky then it was off to
sleep in the cozy tent which had been
decorated with a birthday banner there
was even a little tent and campfire on
top of the chocolate birthday cake
Tyler's family found a fun way to bring
the wilderness into their own backyard
for a birthday he will surely always
remember minecraft parties lots of kids
are fans of the Minecraft video game so
it makes sense that they would want
minecraft themed birthday parties these
parents pulled out all the stops to
create a couple of epic minecraft
parties they had everything Twizzlers
cut to look like TNT green cups with the
creeper face stuck on and a green grass
covered table to enjoy snacks and treats
with friends for activities they had
creeper dodgeball musical blocks a ghast
pinata and minecraft crafting they even
came up with a clever take on pin the
tail on the donkey called pin the tail
on the inner dragon
the kids had to wear a big Minecraft
creeper head so they couldn't see the
most memorable game was light the TNT
the clever mom put a small bottle of
Diet Coke inside a box decorated to look
like TNT then she gave the guests little
redstone torch
boxes filled with Mentos and told them
to light the TNT the Mintos made the
Diet Coke explode giving her look of a
mega TNT explosion the goody bags were
green with the creeper sticker on the
front they had blocks of or minecraft
bookmarks and stickers assorted bars and
creeper cups the party was a big kids
carnival party
according to Martha Stewart creating a
carnival party is easy she suggests
filling up water balloons with air and
string them together to make fun
garlands we found some pretty epic
carnival parties in the mom blogger
universe this party had a guessing booth
where she filled jars with candy and let
the kids guess how many were in there
there was a homemade ski ball game and
face painting the winners got to pick
from prizes at the prize booth other
party planners let the guests make their
own fishing poles with sticks strings
and magnets and then the kids try to
catch fish stuck to magnets for prizes
this one mother got creative with a
toilet paper toss into a hole that looks
like a toilet seat a giant sized
tic-tac-toe game and a sand art station
this is a party the whole neighborhood
will want to go to rock star party this
kid's mom made him a rock star for a day
and he was super stoked about it for
invitations he handed out handmade
backstage passes the kids made their own
guitar picks and got to play instruments
in a little rock star jam session this
party had a cake made in the shape of a
guitar fun labeled sodas with pictures
of the birthday boy on the front pop
rocks and a rock star cookies another
mom went with the glam rock world and
painted her child's face like David
Bowie
she had a bounce house a tattoo parlor a
photobooth and live music they had a
live band singing all of the birthday
kids favorite hits
they even made cupcake microphones with
ice cream cone handles when it was time
to sing happy birthday the band invited
all the kids on stage with their blow-up
guitars to jam out and sing all the band
played behind them making it look like
they were actually playing the song
truly epic and that was ten epic kids
birthday party ideas we hope you enjoyed
the video thanks for watching
[Music]